sommer sonne strand und meer urlaub
könnte so schön sein zumindest wenn er
nicht aktuell die anreise schauen sie
auf diese bilder deutschlands flughäfen
die versinken zurzeit im chaos lange
warteschlangen vor der
sicherheitskontrolle vor der abfertigung
überall und hat man das erstmal
geschafft ja das nächste problem kommt
dann direkt denn die koffer fehlen grund
für die flughafen katastrophe laut nrw
arbeitsminister karl josef laumann sei
der personalmangel aber auch die
schlechte vorbereitung der
flughafenbetreiber er sagt es wundert
mich schon sehr dass die arbeitgeber
bisher nur vereinzelt stellen in der
jobbörse aufgegeben haben zum beispiel
in düsseldorf nur 13 stellen für
gepäckabfertigung und nur eine stelle
für einen luft sicher für ein
luftsicherheitsassistenten und auch die
bundes-cdu findet es reicht sie fordern
die ampel auf die probleme endlich und
vor allem zügig zu lösen unions
fraktionsvize ulrich lange von der csu
sagt die aktuelle lage an unseren
flughäfen ist indiskutabel sie ist
peinlich und sie schadet dem ansehen in
der welt von deutschland bei uns ist
jetzt claudia müller
tourismusbeauftragte der bundesregierung
schön dass sie bei uns sind frau müller
es kann auch jetzt nicht ernsthaft seine
dass man überrascht ist vom ende der
pandemie und vom anfang der
urlaubssaison
wir haben kein ende der pandemie wir
sehen ja momentan ganz klar auch sehr
steigende infektionszahlen und das ist
schlägt sich auch mit an den flughäfen
nieder wir haben auch zusätzlich zu den
personalmangel ein extrem hohen
krankenstand wenn man bei fraport 50
prozent krankenstand dann kommt das
natürlich auch noch mal oben drauf wir
sehen das auch bei den airlines das
cruise sich nicht rückmelden bzw
krankmelden ganz kurzfristig das heißt
das kommt noch mal auf das problem hinzu
wir haben einen personalmangel das
hatten wir bereits vor der pandemie das
muss man sehr klar sagen und während der
pandemie sind dann nochmal menschen auch
gegangen sie haben sich umorientiert
zeit oder befristete verträge wurden
nicht verlängert und diese menschen
kriegen sie nicht kurzfristig zurück
weil die eben den anderen bereichen jobs
gefunden haben sie sprechen jetzt von
einem zeitpunkt schuldig wenn sie
darunter welche von vor der pandemie das
ist ja jetzt schon zwei jahre her und
wenn sie sagen selbst davor war das
problem und warum kriegt man das nicht
in den griff wer ist dafür
verantwortlich wo ist der fehler
erstmals sind natürlich
privatwirtschaftliche unternehmen die
natürlich für ihre personalrekrutierung
zuständig sind was wir jetzt im
politischen raum machen ist es gab ja
die diskussion über die 2.000 türkischen
facharbeiter die her geholt werden
sollen die bundesagentur für arbeit hat
da jetzt gestern die global altena
zulassung genehmigt also dass diese
arbeit auch wirklich das visa bekommen
können damit sich schnell hierher geholt
werden das ist gestern passiert das war
die einigung der flughafen mit der
bundesregierung dass wir da jetzt sehr
schnell helfen wichtig ist aber auch
natürlich die sicherheitsüberprüfung die
stattfinden müssen denn die menschen
arbeiten nun mal in
sicherheitsrelevanten bereichen wie
werden trotzdem durchgeführt aber auch
da ist man dabei die dokumente so zu
verwalten dass das möglichst schnell
passiert so dass diese menschen die
sozial bereits vorkenntnisse haben wir
sind dass die arbeiten an flughäfen in
der türkei hier dann auch schnell
eingesetzt werden können wann wird es
denn besser was kann man dann können wir
das schon irgendwie weil man traut sich
ja jetzt mittlerweile gar nicht mehr
irgendwie an den flughafen zu fahren
weil man diese bilder sieht und denkt oh
gott da habe ich schon gar keine lust
mehr auf den urlaub wann wird es besser
die branche und auch die politik
verarbeiten da sehr intensiv daran jetzt
wirklich schnell lösungen zu finden
sollte bei den sicherheitskontrollen
dass man guckt dass man das auch um
organisiert das an den bereichen auch
menschen zum beispiel von der
flughafensicherheit arbeiten denn die
sicherheitskontrollen das ist
hoheitliche aufgabe da sind von der
bundespolizei beauftragte unternehmen
die dürfen das machen da darf die
flughafen security momentan nicht hier
synergien zu finden es wird auch
vorbereitet dass tatsächlich
bundespolizisten aushelfen das heißt
hier sind wirklich dabei sehr schnell
und sehr kleinteilige lösung zu finden
die größeren themen dabei thema wie wir
die sicherheitsüberprüfung schneller
machen will bestimmte organisations
punkte machen das diskutieren wir auch
sehr intensiv mit der branche das
zusammenzufinden und man muss auch sehr
klar sagen wir haben natürlich eine
marktliberalisierung in der
vergangenheit gehabt auch durch die
europäische kommission getrieben die wir
nicht zurückdrehen werden die frage ist
jetzt also wie wir rahmenbedingungen so
zu setzen dass wir auch attraktiver
werden an den flughäfen dass diese
arbeitsplätze attraktiv wenn dass wir
wieder auch mehr personal dort
hinbekommen denn wissen ja alle
fachkräftemangel ist jetzt kein thema
was uns nur an den flughäfen begegnet
sondern ein in jeder branche und da
müssen wir gemeinsam gucken wie wir die
arbeitsbedingungen zu machen dass diese
jobs attraktiv sind jetzt ist es ja auch
so die preise explodieren und auch eben
gerade beim reisen also flüge dass das
reisechaos es ist ja nur ein punkt dazu
kommt dass alles immer teurer wird wie
will man das stemmen da sind wir ja auch
gerade jetzt ganz aktuell dabei thema
die entlastungs pakete die wir haben das
absenken oder die abschaffung der eeg
umlage die die energiepreise wieder
verringern soll das sind schritte die
wir nicht nur speziell auf das reisen
auf den tourismus machen sondern
grundsätzlich wie wir verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher und auch die industrie
entlasten können ich will aber bei dem
punkt noch ein aspekt dazufügen durch
die flugausfälle die wir hatten haben
natürlich auch die reisenden anspruch
auf die rückerstattung beziehungsweise
bei großen verspätungen auf
entsprechende entschädigung hier wäre es
auch wichtig dass die fluglinien ihren
ja ihren regeln danach kommen wirklich
schnell und zwar innerhalb von sieben
tagen sind derzeit müssen sie die preise
zurück erstatten das auch das passiert
denn wir haben in diesem bereich das
system sie müssen ihren flug in vorkasse
lange lange vorher bezahlen und warten
dann auf das geld was ihnen ja auch
fehlt wenn sie eine umbuchung machen
oder sich vielleicht auch bei der reise
noch orientieren wie die
verbraucherinnen verbraucher die reise
und brauchen dieses geld ja auch
dringend wieder zurück
das geld braucht man zurück aber die
erholung hat dann immer erholung hat
nicht da dann auch wieder ein bisschen
stress aber gut da muss man sich dann
geben dann hat man immerhin das geld
zurück für den nächsten urlaub vielen
dank frau sommer für diese platzierung
für den sommerurlaub
die lage eher ein organist analyse danke